as you become more popular and you
become more influential there's a point
where you know the Kobe Bryant said the
world or I mean I don't know the Tom
Brady's of the world you become your
friends they these guys you know they
get to know you and and perhaps you've
said something great about them
but then do you worry as a journalist if
I'm friends with these guys how hard is
it to be objectively critical of these
guys before friendship takes place
the boundaries are set
your personal life is your business but
what you do on the field or Court of
play in front of thousands in attendance
and millions watching that's my domain
and what you're not going to do is
compromise telling me what the hell I
saw would you ever get my phone call
I don't know who's who's one of the
coach the soul yes uh he scared me now
he scared me
Kobe's scared to live a [ __ ] out of me
because here's why Kobe was a savant
you did not know more basketball than
Kobe Bryant right so when Kobe Bryant
called you
to complain and this is exactly I can
quote him I mean oh I miss him so much I
can quote him for you right now
foreign voicemail
you know who this is [ __ ]
get your ass up
pick up the [ __ ] phone and call me
back that [ __ ] you just said
don't keep me waiting for so long either
your ass better not go on the air and
say some other [ __ ] before you talk to
me
what
did you say I would say something along
the lines of you know something I don't
like the way he's playing it's selfish
basketball right now look at this shot
look at that shot selection look at this
decision what the hell is he doing blah
blah blah and he called me up and so he
called me up and I'll be like this what
now man and he's and he'll say
look you say you watching basketball the
[ __ ] watch the game you didn't
see this person do this you didn't see
him do this you didn't see this dude
missed this back cut you didn't see this
dude Mrs dunk you didn't see him drop
the damn three passes that I threw to
him over the first [ __ ] 20 minutes
what the [ __ ] are you talking about and
by the way you see here and you see this
coach right he don't know what the [ __ ]
he's doing Steve he don't know what he's
doing Stephen hey what you doing what
you talking about so you gonna bring up
all that [ __ ] about me but you didn't
bring up that and I went like this
what we were talking about you
I get all what you saying but that don't
absolve the [ __ ] you did and then we get
into it and he said wow and then he'll
go like this I have no idea why I love
your ass I really don't sometimes I
really really don't but I love you he
said but you're going to end you say
that [ __ ] again I'm calling you to curse
your ass out oh what an honor yeah to
have Kobe Bryant one of the greatest
basketball players to be so invested in
your opinion